hola bienvenidos una vez más a esta
emisión de canadá en las américas café
aire espacio del programa en español de
radio canadá internacional la emoción la
emoción si la emoción de la carga cada
semana estamos una vez más aquí en el
estudio un equipo reducido hay pero pero
calidad paloma martínez también bien
bien
rufo valencia complacer el gusto en
estar con ustedes en todas partes allí
donde estén mi nombre es luis laborda
saludamos a todos los que nos están
siguiendo a través de facebook live en
los controles y está nuestra operadora
tania y aquí presente ayudándonos con la
técnica ar que también estuvo con
nosotros la semana pasada ante la
ausencia por esa extraña locura de
vacacionar que ha tenido nuestro
compañero
y va a volver la próxima semana está de
vuelta la próxima semana ya estará
jugando nuevamente con nosotros les
recordamos como hacemos siempre que
además de el canal de facebook live del
cual ustedes disponen ya través del cual
ya mucha gente seguramente nos estará
viendo también tienen disponible la
emisión en nuestro canal de youtube
y por supuesto el tradicional y nunca
suficientemente encantado difundido
apreciado sitio de internet www rs y net
punto sea y es ahí donde está todo todo
el contenido que nosotros hacemos bueno
también en facebook tenemos nuestra
página facebook que tengo la impresión
que la gente nos sigue siguiendo más a
través del sitio por qué porque hay más
respuesta a los reportajes que
presentamos en el sitio internet que en
los comentarios que la gente hace en
nuestras publicaciones sobre facebook
habrá gente nuevos y entonces en
facebook si nos ven en el programa pero
quiero decir las publicaciones diarias
como hacemos nueve publicaciones diarias
tal veces la gente no comenta gran todo
el materiales y gracia entrevista los
reportajes las noticias los audios
etcétera etcétera lo que hemos trabajado
lo que estamos trabajando y lo que vamos
a trabajar
pero bueno recuerdo entonces que ustedes
tienen ya más de una vía de comunicación
para ponerse en contacto con nosotros y
los invitamos a renovar ese contacto
semana a semana esperamos como éste
estaba de encontrar nuestro nuestro
sitio porque a veces justamente para
compararla para compartir pero también
para ver quién es que cuando nos
escriben mensajes para estar al tanto de
cómo nos reciben nuestros amigos oyentes
videntes esta es televisión
nuestra visión es radio y también en
estéreo si soy un radial bien vale es
bienvenida
bueno sí y como como rufo dice ay ay ay
mensajes de nuestros oyentes que llegan
continuamente y he accedido por primera
vez aunque ustedes lo han hecho muchas
veces antes a una lista a la cual yo no
había accedido antes he descubierto que
hay 260 mensajes sin responder sin
revisar más que sin responder porque no
todos esos no y además no todos esos
mensajes demandan una respuesta y
algunos son información
es que no llegan por ejemplo así que
como hacemos siempre si en el caso de
alguno de ustedes hay mensajes que no
son respondidos con la celeridad que
ustedes esperan
somos unos poquitos efectivamente bueno
quiero además anunciarles a nuestro
público a nuestros amigos a todos los
que comparten este espacio con nosotros
que en el día de hoy van a tener tres
temas musicales y antes en un sauce 2
yo voy a devolver la palabra referencia
que me está demandando la atención aquí
tenemos a nuestro amigo luis balderas
que está saludos desde san antonio en
chile el fin de semana cambiamos de
horario a horario de verano así que
ahora en chile los escucho pasada la una
de la tarde que estén muy bien ya
cambiaron el fin de semana para este fin
de semana pasan al verano entonces es
empezar que nosotros entramos hacia el
otoño
[Risas]
y también tenemos otro amigo que nos
está viendo juana match y que creo que
si mal no recuerdo él está en parís o en
francia algún lugar en francia entonces
esta es juan ya no sé escribir a
extrañamos esas voces en español que nos
llegaban desde sitios impensados en
algún momento la áfrica ecuatorial
tenemos un buen amigo es visible en
marruecos está que les está pasado había
uruguayos que estaban desde el congo en
el congo
haciendo parte justamente de los cascos
azules y teníamos también algunos
mensajes desde japón nos han descubierto
en nuestro nuevo formato vídeo
y además uno se descubre y descubra
manos entonces les decía que en la
versión web que nos siguen a través de
la versión web hoy van a tener tres
temas musicales de dos artistas que
comparten el apellido sant marí pero no
son la misma persona
creo que no que no son familiares son
dos mujeres de 22 artistas una de ellas
es anne marie y la otra es bosque san
marín grandes artistas ambas si a
posible programa de morne ocasión no sé
si ustedes sospechan que puede gustarme
el trabajo que ya hace y efectivamente
esta sospecha en este caso sería
correcta a mí me encanta lo es en mí
tiene música hermosa sí sí uno de esos
temas hermosos creo que es uno de los
que vamos a escuchar hoy ella va a
interpretar maní
dos temas
getting started empezando la cosa
empezando el programa y mantener el
nombre de la canción de chloe es el
nombre de una comunidad indígena en la
costa
norte de quebec que si ella hace de más
canciones en inglés en francés y mentón
acá inventó una lengua también para una
canción bueno y tiene canciones en y no
hay moon que es la lengua que hablan uno
sino en el este de quebec y en labrador
así que la música viene por ese lado
quienes nos siguen a través del sitio de
internet mantener entonces esos tres
temas musicales
tenemos el mensaje juan respondió él
está en parís memoria es un mensaje que
recordaba que ya son así más o menos a
seis y media de la tarde y aquí tenemos
un mensaje de de luis balderas que dice
algo pasa con el audio que se oye otra
transmisión de fondo y ayer nos ayer no
en la última emisión así que estamos
intentando que ese tema sea solucionado
lo más pronto posible bueno como para
arrancar aunque ya hemos arrancado
cuáles son los temas que le llamaron la
atención a ustedes durante estos últimos
siete días algún tema en particular
fuera de lo que es estrictamente actual
o actual si ustedes quieren yo hice una
noticia que me llamó la atención y por
eso la hice por eso me interesé en esa
noticia ya hemos hablado probablemente
de ese tema de todos aquellos niños y
jóvenes también adultos pero
principalmente niños y jóvenes que se
encuentran en la lista de prohibición
aérea o de exclusión aérea canadiense es
una lista que el gobierno de canadá
particularmente el ministerio de
seguridad pública creó entonces esta
lista incluye a gente que es peligrosa
para la seguridad pública del país
sin embargo hay niños y adolescentes y
adultos que tienen nombres sea similares
o iguales a personas peligrosas a
delincuentes a terroristas etcétera
entonces esos jóvenes y niños tienen
muchísima dificultad para viajar
entonces esta semana finalmente después
de muchos años de una larga pelea por
parte de los padres de estos jóvenes
el ministro de seguridad pública rafael
se encontró con ellos porque les dijo
tenemos que encontrar una solución claro
que no tienen que poner en peligro la
seguridad pública del país y tiene que
haber un control muy claro de la gente
que entra y sale del país sin embargo no
pueden coartar la vida a gente que tiene
un nombre semejante al de un delincuente
bueno pero él no pone en riesgo no poner
en riesgo la seguridad del país digo
cuando un niño de 3 años llega al
mostrador de neuro línea el padre lo
nombran y dice a este señor esta persona
es un terrorista tiene 40 años y este
tiene 3 lógica y forma parte de esas
políticas
pero hay niños que han dejado llorar por
seis horas tal vez son el terror el
terror familiar y de quienes tienen la
ocasión o la o la maldición de estar
cerca en algún momento sobre todo tienen
dos o cuatro años
de los terribles dos y no decimos el
cual por el que ford pero él cree que
sería feo entonces el séptimo país
estaría ya en vías de solución
exactamente entonces se encontraron con
el ministro rodeado de seguridad pública
una una comitiva digamos de este grupo
de padres que se han puesto juntos que
han creado un grupo que se llama no les
voy a decir el nombre exacto del grupo
porque es interesante como lo llaman no
fly list
nokia no playlist kids o sea que no
existen estos niños que se encuentran en
las listas de exclusión aérea que no les
permiten viajar o que los retrasan por
horas y horas porque tienen un hombre
semejante un delincuente si podrá hablar
con el ministro para que también tomen
en consideración alguna política que
haga que los niños que aterrorizan al
ruso valencianos no puedan subir esta
parte me llamó la atención pues
justamente la muerte de la letra
franklin
y uno mayor de la música ha influido
tanto ha estado en películas y
justamente me acuerdo que leía por el
que cuando en los años duros de la lucha
por los derechos civiles en eeuu los
años 60 ella sí salió adelante dijo el
momento dado que estaba dispuesta a
poner la fianza necesaria para liberar a
personas que habían sido apresadas en
dentro de esas grandes represiones que
había contra la movilización de la
población afro afro estadounidense que
buscaba justamente el reconocimiento de
sus derechos básicos hasta los años 40 y
50 la vía a segregación a restaurantes a
un todo y hoy todavía es ese clima ese
clima que no ha sido resuelto el racismo
es justamente es es una una línea matriz
en la historia de eeuu y de todo
imperialismo porque es necesario que es
muy humano también
hay como países dónde donde es más
evidente y ha tenido más
impactos graves y difíciles pero yo creo
que somos los seres humanos me parece a
mí sí pero es claro obviamente que sí
pero eso digamos que no debe ese
argumento no debe servir para atenuar
nada por ejemplo en la organización de
un de la creación de leyes por ejemplo
de políticas en un país sea claro y es
algo que no no ha acabado
justamente montreal y está otra cosa que
también me interesa mucho un grupo de
ciudadanos mundial entes en canadá han
decidido pedir aún que se lleven a cabo
audiencias para poner para discutir
sobre el racismo sistémico que existe en
canadá en quebec y montreal donde más
del 30% de la población de montreal por
ejemplo viene de distintas comunidades
pero solamente el 11 por ciento está
participa
las empleados en las tensiones en las en
empleos públicos
ahora si tú no si uno no abre el trabajo
a todos por igual
creas necesariamente acá bajando y esa
falencia se ve muy claramente en muchos
ámbitos uno de ellos es el más cercano a
nosotros que es entre la comunicación y
el otro es el de la enseñanza se lo veo
muy poca diversidad en los profesores en
los distintos niveles de enseñanza por
ejemplo en expresión artística
paloma participado en más una vez en el
trabajo que tienen que ver con el tema
de la diversidad y en el ámbito cultural
esa diversidad aunque va avanzando
todavía no ha alcanzado los niveles que
debería haber alcanzado ya tomando en
cuenta la composición de la sociedad en
un gp pequeño que esto así porque
también hablan de profesores tenemos
otra profesora que está viendo esa
arabiya
ella es montar en señora bongiorno come
by habla italiana y volviendo por una
instancia ávila
no lo sé volviendo por un instante
aretha franklin con quien a quien
recordaste hace muy pocas horas que
falleció un tema que me llama mucho la
atención es que con ella como con otros
artistas que han tenido una vida
artística tan plena y tan vasta y tan
nutrida por un lado yo tenía la
impresión de que era mucho más grande de
lo que era esperar sí cuando me enteré
que tenía solamente 76 años me
impresionó yo pensaba que era alguien ya
que había pisado los 90 años más o menos
más que eso y no tenía solamente 76 y la
plenitud
o digamos la vida artística llena plena
que tuvo como así la la militancia que
tuvo por diferentes causas las
desarrolló a pesar de haber sido una
madre súper joven tuvo su primer hijo a
los 12 a los 12 o 13 años efectivamente
a los 12 o 13 años tuvo su primer hijo y
eso no le impidió ni mucho menos
comprometerse con muchísimas causas una
de ellas
en su carrera musical incluso en su
carrera musical que bueno dejó huellas
en cuanto artista vivo un encuentro hoy
sobre la faz de la tierra más allá de
que uno sea entendido o no ammán yo no
seguidor o no del soul que es el género
que ella más cultivo no es cierto pues
mira mi hija perdón mi hija que le que
le a la que le encanta ariana grande
conoció ahorita franklin ayer bueno se
hizo consciente de la presencia de
hábitat franklin ayer porque ariana
grande que es una chica que todo el
mundo que todos los niños siguen a
muchos niños siguen pues publicó una
fotografía con aretha franklin y
hablando de la importancia de esta mujer
en el medio musical en el que ya se
desenvuelve y claro aunque mi hija ha
escuchado ahorita franklin en la casa es
simplemente al ver a su ídolo ariana
grande con esta otra con este otro icono
pues entonces hizo la relación entre las
dos y claro la admiración ahí empezó no
entonces sí aquí tenemos una aclaración
juana mayo y dice que está viendo
el programa en francia pero que está
viviendo en bolivia así que no viven en
francia
miguela rovira también está con nosotros
me dieron gusto en saludarte la cerca
nos están efectivamente y sara villa nos
mandó un corazón y dice cordiales
saludos para todos muchas gracias
excelente español cordiales saludos para
todos y un corazón entonces respondamos
en italiano
los antiguos son italianos
[Risas]
aunque aunque aunque en mi familia no
hay sangre italiana yo siempre cuento lo
mismo decir te gusta el paquete
obviamente sí por supuesto pero además
de eso obviamente las inmigraciones más
importantes en argentina fueron la
española y la italiana y si bien siempre
se dice que somos descendientes de
españoles porque gran parte de la
población tiene por supuesto antecesores
españoles hablamos el español o el
castellano como nosotros
así en argentina etcétera etcétera
cultura está teñida de italiano
digamos y sobre todo a mí me pasó cuando
estudie la primera vez por primera vez
en italia en roma específicamente
en más la situación entre ellas por
ejemplo una pelea entre dos empleados
del hotel
en el restaurante mientras todos los
huéspedes estaban esperando para
desayunar y fue el único lugar del mundo
donde vi un expediente de dos empleados
frente a los huéspedes
eso ocurrió hace muchos años dije a
pesar de que uno no tiene sangre
italiana pero por supuesto he tenido
amigos italianos uno está inmerso en la
cultura italiana mucho de los vocablos
que usamos sobre todo en el lunfardo
vienen del italiano o de esa mixtura
extraña entre el italiano el castellano
y las otras lenguas
buongiorno y justamente ver que hasta a
partir de esta de su salud después nos
fuimos a la pelea de los meseros de la
norma de norma de los romanos vendedores
no racionales otro mensaje aquí y el
roaming
rovira dice
saludos desde el calafell tarragona
pasando las vacaciones de verano en un
pueblo costero de la provincia de
catalunya espanya saludos cordiales y
muchos 73 dice nuestro amigo miguel
rovira bueno diciendo de vuelta a los
temas que nos llamaban la atención yo
les traigo el caso de una persona que
algo que ocurrió aquí en que ve que hace
un par de días o en realidad creo que
hacer de alguien que
[Música]
vivió una situación un tanto extraña
creo que ya sé cuál vas a hablar
se llama wyatt el châtelet en la región
de la capital nacional de la ciudad de
québec la policía asistió a una vivienda
particular porque alguien había activado
la denominada el trinomio de botón del
pánico
los efectivos llegan a la casa donde
alguien había activado este botón se
encuentran con la persona que lo había
activado efectivamente esta persona se
encontraba muy alterada y mientras dos
policías dialogaban con él un hombre
esta persona se arrojó al más puro
estilo hollywood
a través de una de las ventanas de la
vivienda de cuántas piezas la casa
era una casa estaban en la planta baja
pero el salto por la ventana se estrelló
de cabeza contra la ventana la rompió o
cambió del otro lado y prosiguió su
derrotero que hizo se apoderó uno de los
patrulleros que habían ido a la vivienda
se llevó el automóvil para de policial
huyó en el automóvil policial y la
policía que había ido respondiendo a
este botón del pánico que había sonado
tuvo que perseguirlo durante 170
kilómetros guau hasta que el buen señor
es presa del hambre se detuvo en un
restaurante creo que fue en llamas
chiche
efectivamente en un restaurante y allí
la policía lo pudo capturar y lo que no
escuché en la noticia es por qué hizo
eso explicó no pero aparentemente está
esta persona es un conocido la policía y
los vecinos le ha llamado la atención es
más grave es el extraño la extraña
instalación eléctrica que tiene la
vivienda algunos sospechan que ya
sabemos que es que es pues fue un
laboratorio de marihuana ni un solo gol
a encantan los comenté el señor tiene
que ver con las cripto monedas
tienen numerosas máquinas funcionando en
conectadas al mercado de las criptas
monedas y por eso necesita esa
instalación eléctrica especial pero
parece ser que es alguien que además
tiene problemas no digo mentales pero
anímicos etcétera así que la policía ha
tenido que entrevistarlo en más de una
ocasión
acaso la visita no terminó de la mejor
manera posible y por supuesto también se
ha merecido un regaño el efectivo que
dejó puesta la llave en el patrullero
que fue y en la urgencia al pobre
policía sólido
otro caso rarísimo que tiene que ver
también con autos y con casas y
viviendas con ventanas estrelladas es el
de un joven que también robo robo un
auto pero en un momento dado comenzó a
acelerar a acelerar a acelerar y
atravesó dos casas y así chocó
como hizo pero esta mujer está muy
lesionado pero en un momento dado
todavía están tratando de saber qué pasó
por qué está tan lesionado que no ha
podido responder a las preguntas de los
policías pero aquí en quebec entonces
voló robó un coche se subió en un
momento dado en una de las calles
comenzó a acelerar y en lugar de irse
por la calle se echó directo sobre una
casa y atravesó la casa entera y
rompió la pared de la otra casa no sería
que no sabía dónde estaba el freno yo
creo que la gente va a pensar que los
canadienses somos conductores
en algunos casos y bueno vamos a ir una
pequeña pausa
[Música]
bueno les recuerdo a todos ustedes que
quienes nos siguen a través de sitio en
internet podrán escuchar tres temas
musicales en esta educación ya nos
estamos acercando al ejemplo que nos ha
dado el grupo valencia y musicalizar con
muchos temas musicales cada emisión en
lugar de una mera cortina musical al
final en este caso ustedes van a
escuchar temas de clubes san marín y de
voz y son mari así que quienes siguen la
emisión a través del sitio de internet
tendrán así la música sonando aquí no lo
podemos hacer porque como es a través de
autos derechos de autor facebook live
sería muy complicado
buffy me hace pensar mucho más y la
matadora de vampiros el nombre pero la
persona no no no
no se parece a la vampiresca está ya
puede elegir a un vampiro
y eso es muy posible bueno vamos a
hablamos siempre de los mensajes de
nuestros oyentes a veces no los leemos
en la cantidad las que deberíamos nos
vamos a pulsear reciben la cantidad que
deberíamos así que vamos a leer algunos
de esos mensajes ahora quien quiere
comenzar para lo marrufo rufo paloma
tengo un mensaje aquí de robinson
mosquera garcía él dice hola amigos de
radio de canadá y nos menciona a
nosotros 3 paloma martínez rufo valencia
y luis laborda es decir es un mensaje
freak
supongo felicitaciones por sus buenos
programas en español agradezco por
entretener e informar al mundo con mucha
independencia agradezco que me pueden
enviar una camiseta con el logo de radio
canadá internacional o una cachucha o
bueno la verdad es que ya no tendríamos
ya no tenemos eso a producto se llaman
sus productos y esos envíos de esos
souvenir esos recuerdos de promoción y
esa parafernalia que teníamos antes para
repartir entre nuestros oyentes ya es
cosas
el pasado es todo amor digital
pero mucho sí y entonces dice
cordialmente su fiel radio escucha
robinson mosquera garcía y participante
activo en el antiguo castor y otros
programas de radio canadá internacional
no nos lo recordamos muy bien a robinson
hace mucho tiempo que nos sigue y dice
sería bueno que hicieran pequeños
concursos eso ayuda y motiva a la
audiencia a escuchar los programas desde
colombia
robinson mosquera garcía muchas gracias
robinson y vamos a reflexionar sobre los
concursos pero mantenemos regalos e
ideas fantásticas y eso si no hay no hay
que regalar a cambio salvo amor digital
bueno podemos preguntar a lo mejor hasta
logramos
un regalito y después nos subimos
también de que hay días en los que uno
nuevo abasto con la tarea pendiente
entonces hay que ver quién se hace cargo
de los concursos porque el que haga el
programa
aquí tengo mensajes de héctor dice sobre
el tema que nada tiene derecho a
pronunciarse sobre los derechos humanos
en la realidad saudita sabemos que ese
fue un choque diplomático entre árabes
holística nada que nada que critica el
pensamiento de defensores de los
derechos humanos en arabia saudita y
ahora ves ahorita que se pone balística
y retirar al embajador expulsó de
embajador retira sus estudiantes retire
inclusive hasta sus enfermos de canadá y
bueno se va al tacho seguramente un
negocio de 15 mil millones de dólares
por vehículos militares bueno
héctor dice arabia saudita es gobernada
por gente que contrata mercenarios para
cometer genocidio es un violador de los
derechos humanos y que nada cumple con
su deber de denunciarlo dice héctor
sobre este tema
yo voy a leer como hemos hecho en las
últimas emisiones
un agradecimiento a quienes nos envían
mensajes ligados a dos cuestiones
principalmente que es la de trabajo en
canadá la inmigración hemos dicho que
los sitios a los que se tiene que
recurrir por cada uno de estos temas no
son precisamente el radio canal
internacional pero por supuesto
agradecemos a todos los que nos envían
mensajes al respecto entre ellos freddy
rojas alberto acosta sánchez josé loor
héctor miguel vargas maría scarlett
solano guerrero pablo ferrari jorge
rojas
eric tapia maría tereza sequeira
espinoza juan ramón moreno velandria
natalie álvaro martínez y cristian
rodríguez urbina algún otro mensaje de
paloma si tengo aquí un mensaje sobre el
tema en nicaragua un país en crisis y
dice javier gonzález nungaray de acuerdo
a esta información bien documentada de
leonora chapman de radio canadá
internacional se concluye y veo
realmente que el pueblo nicaragüense
está pasando por una crisis política muy
aguda el gobierno de daniel ortega
una citación en la que ha sobrepasado el
derecho fundamental de los ciudadanos
que así lo reclaman muchos saludos a mis
buenos amigos de radio canadá
internacional nos dice javier gonzález
nungaray comentando el reportaje de
leonora sobre nicaragua un país en
crisis y es verdad que hemos hecho
varios reportajes sobre la sobre
nicaragua y sobre la comunidad
nicaragüense aquí en montreal también
que se ha organizado un poco par y en
solidaridad con su con su país de origen
muchas gracias a javier entonces rufo
aquí el mensaje sobre un tema que causa
mucho interés y era el de un granjero
canadiense que regalaba su tierra a
condición de que alguien la persona se
quiere a cuidarla y ya trabaje y le
trabaje justamente joana dice joanna
moore ahí escribe y dice hola me
gustaría mucho vivir en canadá y junto
con mis dos hijos y esposo cuidar la
granja mi esposa es un restaurador y
artesano nos gusta crear cosas como de
era pero de árboles caídos nos gusta la
naturaleza pescar sería una gran
bendición sería una gran bendición vivir
allí y los animales que dividen con una
buena inducción
podríamos convivir con ellos y cuidarlos
somos colombianos y nos gusta el campo
dice yo a enamoran en ese mensaje lleno
de deseo de poder ir a vivir esa tierra
que este canje canadiense decidió darla
quien quiera trabajarla en el reportaje
hay información sobre cómo contactarlo a
la persona ahora si mal no recuerdo esta
persona no es que le regalaba la tierra
nadie se la entregaba esta gente y tenía
un espacio para vivir lo podía trabajar
podía obtener sus beneficios de el
producto de su trabajo y compartir las
ganancias no creo que fue un acto tan
bondadoso y no es el chiste si aquí
tenemos otra persona que está con
nosotros es alta si anita marín gracias
por eso nosotros un saludo y creo que
ella vive en montreal no sé
pues anita veía si no revela el misterio
para él si nos dice exactamente en qué
parte está viviendo y por ir vecina de
por aquí
carmen un día los oyentes que son ya
aquí cerca tenían que venir a visitar
si coordinamos con dos o tres al mismo
tiempo y pasan por aquí habrá más en sus
impresiones que pensaban a qué grado ha
llegado su desilusión al conocernos
puede que no sea chiste puede ser no
pero puede ser que también diga nada no
esto es aún mejor
está mejor con el facebook lite porque
live porque de alguna manera nos pueden
ver y ya no pueden hacerse ilusiones de
que somos lo que no somos somos lo que
somos un problema con facebook planchar
mi camisa también así como las que no
son planteables bueno se ha comprado yo
comprobación solplan chablé si te quiero
ver sin tanta bueno entre entre los
mensajes que nos llegan por supuesto
también tenemos aún hoy en nuestros días
aquellas cartas tradicionales solían
llegar por el correo postal
a la cámara
bueno entonces como estas cartas se
están apilando se en algunos casos no
tantas como teníamos antes porque por
supuesto a mucha gente ya ha pasado al
correo digital pero creemos agradecerles
entonces el tiempo que se han tomado y
la inversión que han hecho
en el mail estos caros en enviar estos
mensajes y estas correspondencias estas
cartas y estas tarjetas estas postales
entre otros
rafael nos queda que es de cuba también
marcelo miguelín que nos escribe desde
san pablo en brasil logra bajo a adán y
álvarez peña que es de granma de llamó
en granma en cuba
también maricel gigante tarta o tan tan
no entiendo la letra que es de
guantánamo en cuba también y a luis
camarillo que nos escribe desde el paso
en texas en el sur de los eeuu tenemos
otras de los estamos volando para la
próxima semana o para después si es que
nos queda algún minuto porque como
ustedes saben frecuentemente el tiempo
se nos va como agua entre los dedos
[Música]
bueno ahora entonces le vamos a
presentar los temas que hemos estado
trabajando a algunos de los temas que
hemos estado trabajando a lo largo de
los últimos siete días como ustedes
saben tienen allí entrevistas reportajes
noticias que hemos dicho en el comienzo
de la emisión y en este caso a cada uno
de nosotros le va a sugerir a ustedes
uno de esos temas para que ustedes se
adentren en nuestra tarea si yo hice hoy
hice un reportaje que me encantó hacer
con informaciones por supuesto de
nuestros colegas de civis y porque ellos
tienen claro muchos más recursos y mucha
más gente fuera de la ciudad de montreal
un reportaje sobre la casa de una
ballena en el norte de canadá en el
ártico canadiense de nunavut es el
territorio de más nórdico de canadá
bueno hay otros pero uno de los más
nórdicos en donde se habla y no actitud
y donde viven los inuit y un grupo de iu
no es justamente en forbes servei logró
cazar una ballena gigante una ballena
que se llama en inglés go red web y que
en español la traducen como ballena
boreal es una ballena de alrededor 14 o
15 metros parece que es muy difícil por
eso están muy contentos de haber podido
cazar la porque es muy difícil
cazar a una ballena tan grande este está
además esta ballena esta especie de
ballena está estaba en peligro de
extinción entonces había restricciones
para la caza de esta ballena y
finalmente los inuit lograron obtener la
autorización hace unos años ya pero no
hay no se puede ver la ballena
pero lograron obtener la autorización y
no sólo obtener la autorización que no
es lo único que se necesita sino
realmente lograr cazar la ballena porque
como ya hay más más no más individuos
han logrado que les den la autorización
pero no siempre pueden cazar la entonces
desde hace muchos años que no podían
cazar la llora finalmente esta comunidad
de forbes servei logró hacerlo es una
ballena que además ellos trocean la
cortan en trozos le quitan la piel
porque son es un manjar para los inuit
la piel de la ballena entonces la
separan la piel la separan la grasa la
separan para muchas actividades que
ellos que ellos hacen y que ellos
tradicionalmente
utilizan la cera
la convierten en cera la utilizan
entonces tienen que dividir esa ballena
y la van a compartir entre varias
comunidades entonces en este reportaje
que hice se ven imágenes de la casa
imágenes de una reportera que hable nin
actitud que es del servicio de civis y
nunavut que explica cómo fue que no nos
entiende no entendemos lo que dice pero
vemos todas las imágenes de la casa y
vemos a gente que está muy orgullosa de
haber logrado casa había duda de cuánto
tiempo hacía que no se casaba a una de
estas ballenas pudiste averiguar ya
puede averiguar por qué en un principio
se creía que en 100 años no se había
podido cazar esta especie de ballena
pero finalmente es los periodistas de
civis y le revisaron la información y si
había habido casos de una ballena de
este tipo en los años 2000 ya de los de
los años 2000 pero es muy difícil cazar
esta especie entonces por eso había un
poco de dudas y si era realmente la
primera en 100 años pero no hubo otras
en el año en los años 2001 algo
en el año 2001 pero de todos modos es
muy raro
veinte años más complicado porque cazar
una ballena en momentos en que bueno que
estaba en extinción pero
hasta qué punto las tradiciones
lo que es cierto es que tienen la
autorización del ministerio de recursos
naturales y el ministerio de medio
ambiente de canadá quien tiene una serie
de grupos de expertos que pueden ir a
verificar la cantidad de ballenas que
hay además es una cosa que es
milenarista tradiciones milenarias
entonces si no lo hacen en exceso
tampoco entonces si hay una ballena
entre no se decían que había como cuatro
mil 400 ballenas en esa región nada más
entonces casan una la comparten entre
varias comunidades porque no es muy
poblado en un a burga un poco entonces
cuando cuando las separan pues las
separan equitativamente imagina es una
pérdida de ballena da para mucho rojo
balanza cuál es tu tema el tema es
justamente el este jueves el periódico
estadounidense the boston globe invitó a
todos los periódicos en eeuu a publicar
una editorial desde sus comunidades en
defensa de la libertad de prensa y en
protesta contra los ataques donald trump
entonces inclusive en una sección
discutíamos y el título
fake news for fake president personal
cambiamos por la prensa protesta contra
los ataques a trump y fueron más de 350
políticos que participaron en esta lista
en este proyecto la idea no es tanto
convencer a trump de que respete a la
libertad de prensa porque no voy a
hablar mal de esa persona pero en fin
los hechos muestran que de respecto
conocen o conocen y la r entonces lo que
el argumento de los periódicos y
justamente comencé a explicar a la
opinión pública del valor que tiene una
prensa y de los riesgos que existe en
llamar a la prensa enemigos del pueblo e
inclusive y esto se ha visto en muchas
ocasiones en las reuniones en los en las
buenas reuniones con los mítines que se
organizan en apoyo a donald trump no ha
habido el caso de que hay gente que
acude con una camiseta donde se lee
árbol soga periodista se requiere un
mínimo de instalación básicamente está
demandó estar llamando al linchamiento
de los periodistas entonces
otro elemento grave es que también hemos
entrado a un período en que se llama la
post verdad que justamente conversaba a
propósito con el periodista paul knox y
él decía que justamente el trabajo de la
prensa es evitar caer en la trampa del
cram de caer en un antagonismo y
simplemente de hacer bien el trabajo y
de informar de la mejor manera posible
al público entonces ese es el tema que
recomiendo y justamente aunque es una
iniciativa estadounidense de la prensa
estadounidense hubo un periódico
canadiense el más grande en el país el
toronto star que sí participó y también
justamente explicaba en su editorial
como esa tendencia de llamar fake news
de de cortar y de cortar el oxígeno
democracia que es la prensa una prensa
con pleno ejercicio de sus de sus
derechos también está tomando raíces en
la provincia de ontario que es la más
grande con en la figura del doctor que
justamente restringe cinco preguntas sin
derecho a réplica las zonas las
transferencias de las compañías de
prensa docs de esa provincia que además
el que gana a ontario que son los
conservadores tienen posibilidades de
volver los cargadores tienen la
posibilidad de volver de nuevo al
gobierno notaba y hay que recordar que
los conservadores se ensañaron con mucho
énfasis contra la radio pública así que
es materia para reflexionar y eso es lo
que propongo para esta semana tal vez
habría que volver aquello de que quien
trata de mentirosos a todos los demás es
el que dice la mentira más grande
[Música]
yo en mi caso le sugiero a ustedes si
así lo quieren porque ya no es
compulsivo en una entrevista a cristian
francés voltaire es el es del organismo
transa frontier o payasos sin fronteras
que ya están en guatemala acaban de
viajar allí y van a permanecer hasta el
29 de agosto es decir dos semanas en
total un poco menos para una misión
solidaria con víctimas de la erupción
del volcán fuego que ha afectado a tres
departamentos de ese país y ellos van a
llevar sonrisas me decía a decir lo que
van a hacer entre otras cosas es cuatro
payasos que viajaron voluntariamente con
esta organización
a niños y jóvenes internados en
hospitales de guatemala pero también van
a recrear a las personas que no
necesariamente resultaron heridas y
mucho menos pero que necesitan un
respiro de esa situación dramática de
amargura que viven desde la erupción del
volcán y france me decía que por
supuesto la gente necesita donaciones
reconstruir las viviendas etcétera
etcétera pero también necesitan una
sonrisa necesita distenderse necesita
recuperarse psicológicamente de un
trauma como el que produce la volcánica
todo esto que vamos a orientar lo hace
lo lleva a cabo con personal voluntario
y con mucho esfuerzo por eso al mismo
tiempo han lanzado una campaña de
financiación a la que pueden acceder las
personas interesadas en colaborar y
visitando este artículo o yendo
directamente a la página internet de
identidad que son función si ponen
payasos sin fronteras en nuestro sitio
internet lo encuentros o payasos
simplemente aduana cuando te preguntan
qué haces
por narices rojas y sonrisas y tal vez
tenga que pagar taxis también es algún
mensaje más o no es pero me puso que
tengo que ponerme al día así que de
pronto actualizar el mensaje que te
mande a facebook no tenemos más tiempo
agradecemos a todos ustedes la presencia
saludamos despedimos a nuestros amigos
en facebook live le agradecemos a ruffo
valencia a paloma martínez ha estado
presente con nosotros aquí a tania que
está en los controles mi nombre es lydia
borda a pierre que estás atrás aunque no
los vi de oscuridad y nos estuvimos
hasta la semana próxima
entonces bien nosotros
[Música]
picado